good morning and welcome a couple of
things before we dive into the bulk of
the content first we just want to
quickly think canonical my employer for
making it possible for me to be here
this week certainly a great conference a
lot of interesting speakers and actually
get to be here in attenders is great the
other thing is I just want to give you a
little bit of a high-level has to my
approach to this talk now security
vulnerabilities in our own and even
subsets of security vulnerabilities we
could spend an entire presentation just
talking about those and particularly one
off we could also spend an entire talk
and there are entire talks talking about
specific security vulnerability
mitigations so I'm not gonna do that
my goal is basically to give you a
high-level overview as to what at least
start with what we mean by security
vulnerabilities and the same with doing
a fairly high-level overview of a bunch
of mitigations that exist for these
things
so we're effectively going for breaths
rather than depth so to make sure we're
all on the same page to start with what
are security vulnerabilities basically
you mean that something has gone wrong
it's a design or implementation floor
that exists in software and allows it to
be manipulated in such a way that it
misbehaves to the benefit of an attacker
so in this case we have a piece of
software an attacker is interested in
being mischievous making something bend
and twist it and break it to their own
advantage and that can may mean a range
of different things but in the severe
case we're going to result in the holy
grail which is remote code execution or
RCE
so in this case I can take a machine
somewhere else and basically get it to
run whatever code I want it to run or it
can be things like privilege escalations
so suddenly I've got code running as UID
0 or as root when it shouldn't actually
be doing that but there's a pile of
different classes so we
again spend a whole bunch of time
talking about things like you know race
conditions similar link related problems
we could talk about buffer overflows we
can talk about a whole bunch of things
I'm going to generally stick to a couple
of groups
so what are we mean by security
vulnerability mitigations what we mean
is something that basically makes it
harder to exploit one of these security
vulnerabilities it's a technique they
don't have to be a hundred percent
perfect we just have to up the level
make it a little bit harder in some
particular way ideally we can have a
bunch of complementary mitigations so we
can have things which now make it harder
in one direction we can make something
which makes it harder in a different
direction and then we can use these
together and particular if we you know
pick a pair that happened to essentially
overlap or provide complementary
functionality and we can end up with
something which is a near complete
solution and ideally they'll have
minimal or low overhead you know we
could certainly add a lot of a lot of
mitigations around where we can make
things really difficult but the cost of
doing so is probably be expensive so
again we're looking for things that not
only raise the bar and make it harder
but hopefully are also relatively cheap
so at the end of the day what are we
trying to achieve well we want to make
security vulnerabilities impractical to
export the real world as has been a
common theme this week software is bug
free sorry software is full of bugs
human beings aren't great at writing
software that doesn't have errors in it
whether that be design flaws
implementation floors things that they
didn't you know corner conditions that
they didn't expect so we're always gonna
have security vulnerabilities of some
sort but if we can take security
vulnerabilities which exist but an
attacker isn't actually able to usefully
exploit those to gain RC or raise
privileges then we've effectively
achieved our job so we've basically
blocked or thwarted the attack at the
end of the day whilst the bug exists
we've got time to fix it to patch it to
to deal with it and we don't have
problems which would otherwise occur
again we're looking to raise the bar
through multiple mitigations we're not
looking for a silver bullet and one
thing which is quite important in this
field we want to file closed if
something goes wrong and we aren't sure
about it we basically want to stop shut
things down you know in the case of
failing clothes we actually find bugs
people are aware that bugs is this they
get fixed and obviously we avoid having
that particular vulnerability and again
a lot of the vulnerability mitigations
which I'm going to talk about it's not
very interesting thing a lot of the
earlier ones which I'll cover certainly
in these days a lot of different
operating systems but a lot I have also
right will come out of a particular
project called the OpenBSD project the
OpenBSD project is a fully usable secure
by default operating system so it's a
kernel and use land happens to also be
the home to many other software projects
including things like Bluebird SSL open
ntpd
open smtp do some of you probably have
heard of OpenSSH and Tmax a few small
things but the the interesting part as
far as this talk is concerned is it
effectively a research and development
playground especially when it comes to
security and security vulnerability
mitigations so a lot of the things that
you know I'm going to be talking about
later exist tonight investor day or have
at some point started there and and
ended up in lots of other places the
other thing which I'll certainly note is
that a lot of the mitigations that are
in open beasting aren't necessarily open
basically inventions there are certainly
a lot that up a lot of things have
actually come up as ide the other fields
in other research papers by yeah
presented by other people but they've
actually been implemented in open BSD
very early on and and effectively tested
and investigated there
so before we get into this a little bit
further just you know I'm guessing
there's people here from a lot of
different backgrounds a lot of different
experience a lot of different levels of
knowledge so make sure everyone's on the
same page
I just want to quick revisit over CPUs
and stacks one of the functions or one
of the instructions of the CPU will
traditionally provide is a way for
calling functions strangely this is
often called now call for example and
what this will do is it will push the
current instruction pointer onto the
stack so that we know where we're coming
from and we can come back to it it then
changes the instruction pointer to
something that we say hey we want to
call this particular function and we got
off and we start executing this new
piece of code they also provide
instructions for undoing this so we can
go from saying ok we want to call into a
function now we will actually return
from the function the return will
effectively pop the return instruction
pointer off the stack and we go back to
the code that we were previously running
and we resume execution there this is
very useful it means that we can write
code that's actually you know we can
call a function we can obviously do some
processing come back to it
and we can have a function which calls
another function which calls another
function we can bounce back out of
multiple Liars but the interesting thing
is that we have data that were
effectively storing so we have what we
call a stack frame at the bare minimum
the interesting part is that this
contains the return address or the
return instruction point of value this
is in memory
so pretty much in the early days most of
the attacks centered around buffer
overflows and this was basically using a
some sort of technique we'll find a way
that we could actually overwrite the
return instruction point up on the stack
quite often this is due to incorrect or
missing bounds checks a lot of these
were due to bad or poor or very
difficult to use correctly API sand and
this still exists somewhat today and in
addition to overriding the return
instruction pointer usually the goal was
to supply some sort of shell code that
this would return to and so we would
take something which would simply
overwrite bounds would provide you know
some interesting information including
the return instruction Porter a chunk of
shell code and lo and behold we have a
shell or yeah whatever other thing we
want to exploit one of the infamous
papers on this was published in in fact
back in 96 called smashing the stack for
fun and profit if you haven't read it a
lot of a lot of good reading so we can
have some code like this and if you
don't understand see hopefully it's
relatively easy to follow along but
we're basically allocating a buffer of
256 bytes we put a long string value in
it we don't terminate it which is what
so use this for the strings and then we
call in to some function this function
happens to have declared a buffer with
16 bytes you know the people who have
had coffee this morning will note that
256 is somewhat larger than 16 and lo
and behold we then call a function
called strcpy through a copy and we're
saying basically copy this string over
from one location to another now of
course this is going to simply run off
the end so we're going to have lots of
a's so that we've put in the long string
and once we get past 16 bytes of buffer
we simply keep writing memory that we're
not supposed to touch incidentally
buffer here is a stack variable so it's
placed buffer on the stack
we've overwritten part of the stack
we've then potentially overwritten
destruction but one of things you're
wrong and it goes down home from here
the bunch of ways that we can and we
have mitigated this so these types of
attacks one way of mitigating them or
preventing them is via a thing called
right XOR execute and the whole concept
here is that we mark memory regions as
being either writable or executable but
not both and so what this means is in a
previous example where we'd simply
overwrite the return pointer and we
point it to shellcode or memory that
we'd supplied which we wanted to execute
this no longer works we can certainly
still overwrite the buffer we can you
know crash the program we can have it do
weird things but we can't actually get
it to execute code that we've actually
provided to it and this is a big win
unfortunately this is not a solved
problem yeah there is still code that
exists today you know right XOR execute
it's been around for a long time but
it's still code that today exists which
were actually requires write and execute
permissions most of this exists in jets
or a lot of existing jets particularly
in very large browsers and of course
these are completely secure and not not
interesting attack services to anyone on
open BSD the solution generally do this
has been that we disable write write and
execute champion able together unless a
binary is marked with a WX needed flag
which is a linker flag basically adds a
elf section to it that says hey this
thing actually does require this so
you've actually yeah tell it that at
compile time and it also has to be on a
file system which has been mounted with
WX allowed so we make this as hard as
possible but you know if you're going to
source certain pieces of software from
from ports or packages then you can
still actually get it to work because it
depends on this stuff if you're in a
position to actually address some of
these please do another way that we can
mitigate buffer overflows is via address
trace layout randomization or ASLR and
so what this does is whenever we start a
process we place card data and stack at
Emily selected locations the upside here
is that every single execution of a
program should result in a different
layout if you know exactly where
everything's gonna be placed in memory
it makes it incredibly easy to write a
buffer overflow and I had 30 University
students do it in a very short time span
it doesn't take them long to teach them
and you know for them to learn this and
they can figure it out how to do it but
as soon as you start moving things
around and it's no longer fixed
locations it makes it a lot lot lot
harder we have to actually figure out
what the return instruction pointer
would be we have to figure out where the
codes actually going to be placed in
memory in other words we now actually
have to gain information about the
process in order to actually implement
the exploit we've raised the bar another
way that is or another technique that's
used to mitigate buffer overflows this
via a thing called stack protector one
of the early implementations of this was
a thing called pro-police and basically
the idea here is we have a stack canary
so in addition to pushing the return
address on to the stack we put some
value here and basically what happens is
if you've been attacked for our buffer
overflow and the return address has been
overwritten chances are they've also
overwritten the stack canary so during
the function epilogue we're returning
from a function we simply check to make
sure that the stack area is canary is
intact if it's intact then we infer that
the return instruction pointer hasn't
been overwritten and we continue on our
merry way again this can catch and
prevent a large number of common attacks
that we would be interested in
preventing but you can't work around it
you know if you can identify the the per
object value that's been written to all
these functions and obviously you can
write it there yourself perfect sense or
you can possibly avoid overwriting it in
which case yeah it's a non-issue either
way but again we've raised the bar enter
the new era so these days were more
interested in things like return
oriented programming or 'rock most of
the the trivial attacks were things like
buffer overflows have been interesting
why's that we just mentioned but this is
interesting the whole idea here is that
we now provide our own sequence of stack
frames so we have a series of stack
frames each of these frames is obviously
a return address on the stack and we put
these together to form what we call a
rock chain in essence what rock chain is
is effectively addresses that will
points in memory that we want to return
an execute code from we've probably got
a little bit of data mixed in as well
and we do something to change the stack
pointer to refer to this sequence we
return to the chain and basically we
start and we pull an address off this
chain we start execution each address in
the stack frame list within the rock
chain refers to what they call a rock
gadget and this is simply a piece of
code which provides some sort of
functionality might be an addition might
be a subtraction might be a way to call
a function and perform a system call and
the easiest form of these is on the tail
of an existing function what they call
an aligned gadget so what we do here is
we simply jump into the function midway
through so rather than actually jumping
into the start of the function running
all the function code we find a little
bit of current at the end of a function
which basically increments a register or
does something interesting and we can
jump straight into that point so now
we've got something which can do an
addition or a subtraction and we can
basically take these together and build
up something which becomes much more
complex much more interesting due to
sisk and variable length CPU
instructions there's also lots of
interesting ways that we can do it with
unintended instruction sequences so
these are referred to as polymorphic
gadgets or poly ret and in this case
rather than actually jumping into the
tail of a function we're actually
jumping into some location in memory
which happens to contain the sequence of
bytes that we need to actually run a
particular set of instructions but
that's not what the compiler or the
author of the code actually intended so
we can actually you know analyze a
binary we can pick out a sequence of
bytes and we can simply take that and
run it there's a whole set of tools
around this stuff basically you can say
hey go and analyze this binary and
analyze this library and it
will identify list of gadgets that are
available if we get a basic set of
gadgets we can generate chains we can do
things like hey give me a set of stack
frames which will actually pop a shell
the real interesting thing is this
happens to render right XOR execute
largely ineffective we don't actually
have to have execute all we're doing is
providing data so we can write to memory
we can provide that rob chain we can
then have the CPU executes the code
that's already in the program so as it
mentioned before we simply have a whole
bunch of return addresses possibly some
data mixed in depending on what we're
doing and we go from there but it gets
even better so the one of the original
rock paper one of the more interesting
original rock papers was a thing called
when good instructions go bad and this
is published by the University of
California San Diego in 2008 this was a
follow up in 2014 which came out of
Stanford and basically the interesting
thing here is that we no longer need
access to the binaries to actually build
the rock chains all we need is to find
an existing stack overflow or buffer
overflow and we need a service which
happens to restart itself whenever it
crashes course no one will do this doing
this we can rightly construct a gadget
which allows us to call the right system
core we can call the right system call
we can get it to basically give us the
contents of the process memory and lo
and behold we have a binary that we can
run through normal standard analysis to
give us rope chain we now attack it via
that rock chain we can basically you
know get it to do whatever the
interesting thing here is the the paper
called hacking blind basically
demonstrates ways that they attacked
both Tuohy services but also things like
nginx and MySQL to basically you know
get hold of the the process without
actually knowing what was running and
build up a rope chaining and go from
there
so how can we mitigate Rock
one approach that's used in OpenBSD is a
thing called map stack and this is
basically a memo
flag which marks a memory region as
being stack memory whenever we enter
into or exit from the kernel and then we
check the stack pointer and make sure
that it happens to actually live within
one of these regions which is marked as
stack memory so this means that if you
happen to provide it with a rock chain
which was yeah placed into memory in a
location which happened to not be stack
then we will simply terminate the
program and you know have a nice day but
it does require sorry it can't be worked
around if an attacker is able to call a
map with map sack again it's not yeah a
silver border 100% solution but it does
make things harder one of the other
interesting things which has been added
is a basically an extension to stack
protector or a better version and stack
protector thing called wreck guard so
remember before we were talking about
the fact that if we're using align
gadgets we're basically looking to jump
into the tail of an existing function
and return back obviously in the case of
the stack protectors that's fine because
we still check the stack canary yeah we
can put the known stack canary on there
if we can gain access to it still makes
life harder but with ret guard we're
actually computing and storing a cookie
based on the return address on the
function entry so we take a a randomized
value which is provided on a per
function basis we do a calculation we
store it we then compare on an exit and
we actually verifying that the return
address is what we actually intend it to
be when we call the function again this
makes it a lot harder to actually do
anything useful here another challenge
with Rob is that you know we have what's
known as not sleds which are basically a
series of knop instructions that
typically use for text alignment and if
we have not sleds then an attacker can
be sloppy we don't actually have to jump
straight into
piece of code yeah at that exact
instruction we can jump in where the
knots are and we'll just simply keep
executing not operations or instructions
until we actually reach the code that we
really wanted to execute and we can go
from there another thing that was done
was we basically took the the compiler
generating nops leds and particularly
where they were located in manual
assembly and they were converted to
basically being a jump instruction at
the beginning of that sequence followed
by a whole bunch of entries which now
means that you either have to land right
on the jump instruction itself or at the
jump target landing in the middle is no
longer interesting to you in story
happens to be a debug trap instruction
so you know if you happen to land on one
of these things don't work so well and
there's a lot of work done to reduce the
number of gadgets were available so part
of this of a lot of this work was done
by a guy called Todd Mortimer who's done
a bunch of work on the the GCC and clang
compilers available and OpenBSD and
looked at things like okay we can
actually change the code that's being
generated one of the interesting things
with Siskin modern cpus would usually
have a lot of different ways of doing
the same thing and we also have
selection over what registers were
actually using to do it if we use
certain registers we end up with certain
instructions which are interesting from
a rock perspective particularly the RET
instruction which happens to be a poly
ret we can simply change the code that
thing it's coming out of compiler you
know we can say okay instead of using
that particular ages to use this way
instead suddenly we've taken a polygraph
instead that could be used for Rob
attack no longer exists
and likewise there's a fix-up module in
clang which goes through and basically
does some of this work interestingly the
arm 64 kernel on open Buster's gadget
free arm 64 is using fixed width
instructions there's no polymorphic rets
to deal with the start with and the use
of rec guard protects all of the other
return cases but well that might be the
yeah in goal and and and now if we like
the Silver Bullet it's not necessarily
essential
so on amd64 we have a significantly
reduced attack surface when the same
work was done whilst we can't say we
don't have any you know gadgets
available in the kernel that you can use
the the same work means that if we if we
can review the reduce the diversity of
gadgets that is available then it
becomes much much harder to build drop
chains and one example of this was
running one of the the standard Rob
analysis and chain building tools
against Lib C after some of this work
was done you know previously it could go
through and find eight nine thousand
gadgets and and we could easily build
some some code or a chain that would pop
a shell once the work was done and we're
compiling with things like record and
and removing poly Rhett's all of a
sudden the same tooling can't find
enough gadgets to actually achieve the
same thing so again we're raising about
the following mitigations are
interesting because the general
approaches rather than targeting
specific vulnerability and mitigate
sorry specific vulnerabilities so some
time ago proof job was a thing and got
added to a number of functionality
particularly on open BSD the whole idea
here is that we drop privileges as soon
as possible if we take it at typical
program we're going to normally need to
do some sort of setup we might need to
open a raw socket but after that we
don't we no longer need work privileges
to run so if we change from running as
root to running as a less privileged or
a non privileged user then if we happen
to manage to exploit for example a
buffer overflow in it then it's no
longer as useful as it would have been
previously we can't run code as root
hopefully that means we can't write yeah
shell cuts to the system and those sorts
of things so TCP dump was an example of
this we switch to non privileged user
before we actually start passing packets
now you know even as late as 2017 there
were pausing flaws in TCP dump which
would basically mean that if you had the
ability to put certain traffic on the
network someone running TCP dump as
on a machine you have RCS root and not
what you want precepts and even more
interesting approach to this so we take
a program or provide some sort of
function element we split it up into
separate processes each of those have
different privileges each of these
processes then communicates via some
form of restricted IPC we have common
techniques and things like socket pairs
on MST it's very common to use a thing
called iMessage which is basically
message passing over sockets and it
means that part of the program can
retain privilege whilst the others do
not and we then can ask the other
program to do something on our behalf
check something on our behalf if the
part that doesn't have privilege gets
attacked it's not actually useful how
many have you run a not very well-known
piece of software on your servers called
sshd a few of you okay there's a very
interesting situation with SSH in 2002
there's an integer overflow bug which
basically meant you could attack this
thing and and exploit it severely just
before this SSH had being rewritten to
use or to at least support prep set so
rather than running everything as root
the pre authentication code so
effectively the piece which talks to the
network before it actually even knows
who you are
now runs as a less privileged or a non
privileged user we still have to do
things like check authentication so we
need access the system yeah we have to
at some point potentially if you do
authenticate switch to your user ID and
actually let you login as you so we
still obviously have to have privileges
to do this but we don't have to run the
network facing part which is attackable
and requires no authentication as route
when this integer overflow became known
the solution to the problem was well
part of it was if you're running a proof
that code enabled it's not actually
exploitable OpenBSD had this it was
basically advised
obviously as soon as we publish they
publish details of this particular
attack then everyone's system running
sshd is vulnerable to it all likewise if
they put up a patch and say here go
Patrick oh there's gonna be a window
they could turn this around simply say
okay grab the most recent card and they
will prove SEP and you'll be fine and
these days I believe that the non proofs
that version has actually been stripped
out and you have to run it in present
mode again it's not the first piece of
software to do this you know there were
things like postfix and similar that
were written in qumar which uses the
similar models a long time ago but don't
open based it's common or almost
standard another one is for connect
acute array exact same room we talked
about a SLR earlier we also talked about
be ripe and the fact that if you have a
process which yeah something like engine
X which is forking processes to serve
incoming requests and happens as a crash
well it simply Forks off another one and
execs again if you actually have exec or
react as part of the process of actually
switching yeah changing to another set
of functionality again you're actually
ending up with some new layout thanks to
the execution part so this means that we
place things in different areas of
memory again these attacks become a lot
harder because something which worked
previously doesn't actually work now
a more recent one in order to avoid
having kernel information or code placed
always in the same place the kernels now
shipped as a link kit so basically at
installation time and again at each boot
the kernel is really linked with a
randomized layout and this means that
every single OpenBSD host happens to be
running a unique kernel if you want to
attack that machine you actually have to
work out how to target that particular
layout which means you have to know what
the layout is and so again this requires
discovery which adds yet another barrier
and the same things also been done for
libraries so at boot time lib Ceylon
tripped on LD Dada so which all happen
to be fairly large attacks
as happen to be relinked with randomized
layouts again you know building a rope
chain on your system on someone else the
system doesn't mean that it's actually
going to work everywhere else clutches
one which is relatively new and it has
been a rather interesting journey to
follow along the whole idea here is that
it provides restrictions based on
subsets of system calls this isn't you
there's a bunch of other tools around
that do this you know everything from
SELinux mo capsicum et cetera but the
interesting thing with pledges is it's
actually a specification which is baked
directly into the program so the program
is saying I'm not only going to use the
following and if it doesn't obey to that
then it simply is terminated it can
continue on further to relinquish
subsets of functionality but we can't
actually regain them it's a fairly
straightforward thing to learn easily
implement easy to test yeah if you
happen to say I'm promising that I'm not
going to write files and you do your
program terminates the really
interesting thing with pledge though was
what happened when it was actually being
rolled out to all the system utilities
we talked earlier about the fact that
well we could do things like prove drop
all and we could say hey yeah this
particular program ping for example
needs access to a particular piece of
functionality but it needed if you do
that externally you pretty much have to
retain that for the entire lifetime of
that process with pledge we can say hey
I need access to the internet for
example and then we can go and run some
code and then we could say ok I no
longer need that so we can actually
because it's baked into the program
we're actually in a position where we
can reduce it as we know how to and this
resulted in a lot of code being
rewritten so that things were hoisted up
you know things that needed privilege
were done early on in the program so
that we could then decrease them in a
privilege if we combine this with proof
step we end up with something which is
basically one side has privileges to
talk to the network another process
simply doesn't have any access to
anything other than standard i/o so it
can pretend
reading right from an existing file
descriptor but it can actually do any
more than that so things like TCP dump
or other pieces of code which happen to
need to do pausing or computation we can
severely limit what they're capable of
doing unveils a more recent piece which
is essentially complementary to pledge
but also highly useful in isolation and
this basically hides the visibility of
file systems so we can say okay going
unbale an initial call will simply mask
the file system and then we can say look
make this file visible we'll make this
directory visible and we tell us to say
look you know make this file read-only
or make this file so that we can
actually write to it when you have
programs where for example you're
specifying a file to operate on as part
of the command line we can then take
that we can use pledge and unveil to say
ok yes you still need to be able to
write two files but I'm only going to
let you write to a file which is part of
what you've been asked to write to and
suddenly you know we can't write to
other places in the system or your home
directory or regional SSH keys or
whatever other interests anything is we
might do so we've talked about a bunch
of security minute vulnerability
mitigations these are you know other
considerations things that if we can do
this it will help you as a programmer as
a person running some of this software
but they're not strictly mitigations as
such if you have secured api's then they
are easy to use correctly and they
should be very hard to get wrong in
other words it should be secure by
default yeah yes you can say hey do
something stupid and if you pass in the
right arguments and you know tell it
that your buffer happens to be
substantially larger than it actually is
then it's going to do the wrong thing
but why default we shouldn't be able to
do that it should be obvious and helpful
to you instead one of the early examples
of this was STR I'll copy so we looked
at STR copy earlier which you know
simply said hey we can you know
whatever end of the buffer we happen to
be asked to overwrite of you know I
don't know how long the buffer is I'll
just keep copying it's not a problem
I'll find the end of the string at some
point might be down the end of memory
but not a problem STL copy turns things
around it basically adds a couple of
guarantees and and constraints one is
you as the program I have to tell it how
big the buffer is that you're actually
copying into secondly it guarantees that
if it returns success it will
successfully null-terminated the string
so if you say copy this string into this
location and you haven't actually
allocated or remembered enough roomed
for the null byte it will fail so things
that were previously possible in terms
of bad string handling become really
hard and really obvious jumping forward
a number of years
more recently API was like reality array
racquel array in free zero of been added
again one of the the interesting attacks
is you know integer overflow
multiplication overflow so now we're
asked to allocate memory for some value
times somebody and we don't actually
check that the result is actually going
to end up being able to fit in whatever
size number of bits we actually have if
we do this we can get wraparound and
that does real interesting things
because we can export some of these and
again if it's signed reverse or and so
on yeah obviously that's got some
different implications realloc array
basically says okay you tell me how many
of these objects you want to allocate
memory for you tell me what the size of
the objects are and I'll do the math for
you the math happens to have correct
bounce checks then we can actually go
and allocate it right you as a program
is no longer need to think about this
recalc array is a slightly different
spin on this one of the challenges as a
su programmer if you don't want to leak
information into memory basically you
want to clear it before you free it or
return it and in doing so if you use the
reales functionality basically you don't
know whether it's going to say yes you
can use some more memory in the same
location or whether it's going to have
to do a reallocation
copy your existing data across and free
the old piece of memory now real happily
do this for you if you say okay I want
to realloc this allocation to some
larger size and it needs to go and yeah
okay that won't fit where it is
currently will make yeah and one Meg
area over here will copy it across and
I'll go and free the old thing for you
that's great but now we've got a piece
of data floating around potentially in
memory that we don't want there and so
the constraints all the guarantees as
far as recolor choreo is concerned is
not only will it avoid or do the bounce
checks for you but it will also
guarantee that's actually going to clean
up after itself if it happens to need to
you know reduce or throw away memory we
also have a thing called own malloc
which is supposed to be hard and malloc
implementation has randomized layouts
and allocations with things like chunk
Canaries and guard pages you can enable
junking so it will actually override on
free and this allows you to find bugs
quickly so that they're fixed which also
prevents exploits randomness is an
interesting topic and again one that we
could spend a lot of time talking about
but a lot of the mitigation techniques
mentioned so for example the wreck guard
cookies require randomness in a lot of
other sensitive applications do as well
arc for random on OpenBSD can be used in
any context is always going to succeed
it's built on top of a thing called get
entropy which is a system called below
this also succeeds and does not block
which means as an application developer
you don't need to deal with failures you
don't have to go okay now I'm running in
a chroot I happen to be missing a device
node which I can't open or hang on I
can't open it because I've run out of
file descriptors or you know a bunch of
other interesting failure modes you know
I happen to be even booting up and now
this thing is blocked because it's
waiting to you know give me some
guarantees these things make your life
easier so in summary we can't
necessarily eliminate security
vulnerabilities if you happen to know a
way to do this please let me know well
yeah
we'll go into it possibly get rich
together that sounds great but we can
make them very difficult to exploit or
hopefully impractical to exploit
it's always an arms race there are new
attack techniques so yeah since B Rock
there's a rock there's very other you
know variants and techniques on this
front there's always going to be some
coming up with another way to bend and
twist things so we have new attack
surfaces but the thing is if we have
multiple layers of defense or defense in
depth we can take a bunch of mitigations
we can use them together hopefully you
know find ones are relatively cheap to
do and whilst the software or the system
may be vulnerable we can actually make
it near impossible to actually exploit
and that's what we'd like to do so thank
you I'll certainly take a few questions
just a few pointers here if you're
interested in this stuff the obesity
events page has a ton of talks so
there's you know entire talks on pledge
on unveil on a lot of this stuff one of
them there which I the the rope and
related work that's in OpenBSD as I
mentioned was largely by Todd Mortimer
who presented at us beat euro based icon
the great presentation there if you want
to read through it paper wise I mention
especially the sack fun and profit
earlier when good instructions grabber
and hacking blind all very good reads if
you're interested in a subject thank you
very much got a couple minutes for
questions so stick your hand in there
Thanks so unveil locks off everything
and then enables access to a certain
things so if an attacker has the right
gadget or something they could just
unveil more stuff right so one of the
things that I jumped over one of the
last things that you will do is call
unveil with nala null and basically what
this does is you can no longer call
unveil so there is a way of locking us
down basically saying you know I've as a
program I finished unveiling everything
that I want to unveil near you can
actually manipulate this but yeah thank
you for not using Comic Sans and let me
fix that so a lot of these are quite
OpenBSD specific a lot of us here
presumably use Linux one of these kind
of mitigations are available in Linux so
a lot of the earlier ones are talking
about things like a SLR that's certainly
available in not just links but most
operating systems we know it's calls it
DEP
yeah Mac Kasich cetera has there are any
names for things what I would say is on
the tail end of things so you know
plug-in unveiled as I said there are
certain similar things in terms of
things like you know a polymer SELinux
to me the difficulty there is that
they're applied after the fact so if you
update the piece of software you have to
know what it now needs access to all you
have to give it access to something
which it then has floor lifetime the
process which potentially means that
there's more vulnerable that should be a
lot of the the rockwork so that the
stack protector stuff is available in
Linux I don't know there's the status in
terms of about what's enabled by default
or not by default but a lot of the rock
mitigations particularly the gadget
reduction poly
reduction stuff could certainly easily
be taken and used with with clang and
jisu C compilers there's nothing which
makes that particular part open very
specific things like ret guard obviously
require support in yeah predominantly
the compiler but also some of the tool
chain stuff again there's no reason
these couldn't be ported over yeah
should you choose to do so so if you
interested and want this stuff go ahead
and take it and use it please so all of
these techniques you're talking about
obviously from sort of C C++ low-level
language systems for those of us who
work in high-level interpreted languages
is there anything we can do do we just
have to go nag the interpreter
developers to start trying to find ways
of baking this stuff in or because
they're anything we can do right now
that's an interesting question
or point yeah I think the thing is a lot
of these approaches coming from
different perspectives so a lot of
things I've talked about in terms of
buffer overflow protection and and
various mitigations actually applied to
the interpret I mean that the
interpreter aspect it's a lot more
secure yeah we've recently seen bugs in
Perl and other interpreters where you
can actually give it bad code and have
it do things so you actually gain from
the stuff that I've been talking about
there but things like system calls like
pledge you can actually call to from
yeah script languages and and other code
so if you know that you're writing
scripting language which is only going
to do a small subset of things obviously
you can employ these these techniques
things like prove drop proof set that
also calling pledge and unveil if
obviously there's a little bit of work
to do to do that but it's certainly
possible that's all we have time for
please join me once more in thinking gel
for coming
[Applause]